メリークリスマスみんな和美社長です12月の26か
クリスマス意味でございますと皆様ご存知の通り
なんかクリスマスというのやっぱね男女の値段と上の
少し付けするパリ24dec なんですけども
24dec の午後9時から翌日の25日の午前3時までの6時間は
1年間で最も男女は
1主主シティでございます性の6時間と言われております
いろんな人がね男女でラブラブしてるわけですよ
どういうことだ突発的には許せないんですよ許すなそう俺たちが遊戯王カードスライド
も
奴はもう我々はこっちの性を大事にしたいクリサーチはセイントセイだから夜だからさ
こっちの背よりこっちの性を大事にしたいので俺たちは俺たちだけどクリスマスを
楽しまこれたちの性の6時間は静かなる性の6時間ということで今から6時間正座し
ます性の6時間の間は
た
はいというわけで6時間低座スタートです
25日の3時まで星お時間をいただきます
ています
これどうなるんだろう
ちょっていっ
もうだって
すると主 new 思いができますじゃあ俺は今日6回すると2時間あければ
中思い以上のフェ
それでお坊さんたちは約のマネー
今年のクリスマスは雨が非道ございます
様
自分の好きな
その人がいたんですその人がなんともくっついて来てくれた山
写真撮れたんですその時は気付かなくて終わった後に写真撮ってくれた人が俺の所に来
て居る事に
このよくついてですこの言われていい
それを持って行っ me to do まだブーブーも何クローン
ブーバ身の毛で嘘の人ができるぬ福市
終わった後母親の髪の毛とかな辛さを粉を買ったぞ奴は総じて良いでしょ
しびれる原因が血が溜まってるだったら本当に良はすっ
なぜはもうおっこーさんだよ血流が悪いとか悪くなってるだけですよ待って待って待っ
て
本当に居る方に大丈夫かな違うと思った
2グリーンながらやろ違って何か違った音なくて名前ですね爆血流が悪くなって何か
おかしなことになるとかいい事を
あまり精神が充実
nk 傘で眠くは内の消防防ぐ
リンチ召喚いいことしかないですん
じゃあこの明日の守備では何
星座守備でしみたいな星座しびれない骨にポツが4つある声がかからない
えっ危ないコツはい背筋を伸ばし体を前に傾け
お尻を触れる程度に浮かせるパターン
空傾斜や投資用若干逸らせる足の親指を重ねる
ます
2グリップザック紡ぐあのかなりデクスターはなくなってくっつーかで刺さってた
今のダイブが気になりません9粒あとは右手をした左手上にして重ねる
これ
デリ嘘座
22時になりました
1時間経過したところで感じたのは足がも限界ですそうぞや美大ぐらいなんですけども
俺は負けたくありません戦います
突破し参拝
ちょっと待ってちょっと帰ろ帰ろ増加する
ちょっと寒さの限界なんで買えるを追加します
ああ私の危機を感じていますが大丈夫なんですね
あれ23前時間経過しました
うーん多分コザ今一番頑張り時だと思いますしびれはもういいですそれをしました
ね使命起こしてあしっくりとかの筋の伸び方が以上でこの先ができる不安なレベルです
また寒いですじゃあもう4時間頑張りますこれちょっと待ってをちょっと限界かも信じ
時間ラインだと思うんだよ
はっはっは
罰ですよ
これやばいはもう行かスザーノ微調整も効かないにもいます
2月25日になりましたメリークリスマース
ありがとうございますありがとうございます
はいみなさん今年もねクリスマスぜひね恋人同士でも住吉署
トイレ竹飾りくださいすいません
あっ近づくないねっ
スマッシュん
えっトイレだけを見させられちょってきますね
植木で5分からスタートにスタートします経験月よりきついと思うたび動いてんちゃん
だってこっちは生だから桜かな
あいつら生
俺たちゃせ
すいません
終わった方々コンっ
もうちょっと寒すぎて限界なのでちょっとおでんを食べます
ただ星座はずっとするので安心してくださいいただきます
8歳分発
ブーブーいいっ
湯其の二十
はい1時になりましたお時間経過したわけなんですけども徐々にそのくりすまーす
めちゃめちゃするコンピュートに対する憎しみが消えつつある日スマゲームを楽しく
できるようになってきましたありがとうございます
ただ
足は痛いです
1:32ですあと一時間半でございますねえ
えっ
ん
はい
12月25日午前2時となりました
素晴らしいと思います八ッ橋れいよいよ
聖なる6時間保残り1時間となりましたもう悔いはありませんっここまで来ると痛みと
彼は常に痛いにょ誰かカード買ったかってニョクわかんなくなっちゃっ
心が洗われる気持ちです頑張りましょうぞ
ん
はっはー
日本の見えメインバー
魚世界が海ジャム
こういうをしようじゃないかうおうおうおーー
2時半でございます
残り30分に刺し店マップなんですけどもみ狂いと眠気吐き気頭痛が止まりません
ん
が男の勝負だ
voodoo
はい
性の6時間
終了でございます
実に清々しい自分です何みたいなのをすべて
たつけることができました我々は本物成人としてこのように限りしようと思います
me
uh
ni
me
消えずシーン
me me
いいいい
いいいいいい